One downside of using the native dom selectors,
such as document.querySelector or document.getelementbyID is
that what is returned is a dom node and not a D3 object.
If we try to call any D3 functions on what's returned from the dom selectors,
we'll get an error saying a method is not defined.
In order to leverage the full power of the D3 chainable API,
we need to create a D3 element from a selection so
that the selection is wrapped with all of the functions D3 defines.
The d3.select function looks very
similar to query selector defined in the api of the dom.
And just as we passed in .viewermain as a CSS selector to
signify that we want a dom node that had class viewer-main,
we can do the same with d3.select function.
Notice what gets returned is an array rather than a single dom node.